okay let's go to our next caller from
the six-30 area code caller from six-30
what's your name where are you calling
from what's your question
I'm calling from Chicago and my name is
Gerardo and my question was I know that
I was watching the interview you did
with Dave Rubin
a while back and I was wondering when
you were actually going to do the
interview on his show oh when I'm going
to be on his program yeah no I mean
basically the last we talked about it
it's an open invite for whenever I'm
next in Los Angeles I think he wants to
do it in studio and not via Skype so I
don't know right now I might not get to
Los Angeles until April of next year so
it might not be before that if at that
time he's still willing to have me I
don't know if the offer is good if it
has an expiration date on it you know
yeah I was actually wondering if you
guys had a falling out over your
interview that's why I was curious and
why you brought up the question I'm
sorry if we I can barely hear this call
he's wondering if you've had a
falling-out with Dave Rubin since the
interview oh I mean sorry what was that
I was just wondering if you had had a
falling-out because of the interview you
guys did got it got it I honestly don't
know the answer to that if I knew the
answer for sure I would tell you I've
not talked to Dave much since the
interview and I know that I pressed him
on some issues and there was reaction to
that online and he's not indicated to me
that he's upset with me for the
interview where I asked questions about
health insurance and Taxation and all
sorts of other policy I could I couldn't
say one way or the other honestly well
it was it was an excellent interview and
oh you got a great show going on man so
thank you all right appreciate it
appreciate it